- [Narrator] All right
then Stranger Things fans,
if you're watching this
then we're assuming
you've had time to catch
all of Stranger Things 3.
Well if you haven't, don't
know what you're doing
watching a video about
season three theories
because, fair warning, there
are a lot of spoilers to come.
(banging)
(intense music)
- [Dustin] Copy.
I repeat, copy.
This is a code red.
- [Narrator] Okay, now we've established
you've seen all of Stranger Things 3.
Today we're gonna talk about one of
the biggest shocks of the season.
So, let's dig into the
theories around Hopper's death.
Disclaimer alert, we're not
confirming or denying anything.
These are purely fan theories.
Let's take you to episode eight.
Quick recap.
Hopper and Joyce dress as Russians
to shut down the gate to the Upside Down.
The thing that's letting the Mind Flayer
turn people into mush.
Hopper wins a fight, yay!
Tells Joyce to shut down the gate.
Even though he won't be
able to get out in time.
Joyce is like, oh no.
Hopper's eyes saying, do it.
So she does, and it's
bye-bye to these Russians,
and bye-bye to Hopper.
Or is it?
Because this is where the theories start.
Fans are a little bit
skeptical about whether
our pal Hopper is actually dead or not.
Let's take a look at the
evidence fans on Reddit
have compiled to support their
Hopper ain't dead theory.
Reddit user HouseHeisenb3rg--
How do you pronounce the three as an E?
Uh, I don't know.
Points out the lack of a body.
The way Hopper's final scene was shot,
the machine explodes with
Hopper right next to it,
but when Joyce approaches
the scene afterwards,
there's no body.
(crying)
Why is this important?
Well, if you go back all
the way to the first episode
of season three, we see
exactly what happens
to someone if the machine explodes.
(exploding)
Yuck, yeah.
It's not a pretty sight.
Exhibit two, according to
Reddit user Montgomery7248,
really loving that topic title by the way,
is the music that plays when
Eleven reads Hopper's letter.
♪ I ♪
♪ I will be king ♪
Recognize that song?
Fans have pointed out
that's the same cover
of David Bowie's Heroes
played in season one
episode three, when Will's body was found.
And everyone believed he was dead too.
♪ I ♪
♪ I will be king ♪
- It's not Will.
It can't be.
- [Narrator] Of course, it
turns out Mike was right.
It wasn't Will.
Or, as Montgomery7248 puts it,
I can't think of any reason
that they would've picked that song,
given the countless songs
perfect for that situation,
other than them subtly calling back
to another time where
we were told a character
was dead when they weren't.
If Hopper isn't dead,
where the hell is he?
Fill your boots, fans have
plenty of suggestions.
The biggie is that Hopper somehow
found a way to the Upside Down.
Or as Strangerthingsideas puts it, hopped.
I see what you did there.
That is a truly terrifying prospect
given what lives there.
(roaring)
Another popular theory is related
to the after credits scene.
(speaking foreign language)
Hang on, hang on.
Which American?
Well if you ask theupsid3down,
again with the threes and the Es,
Hopper could've landed in Russia
rather than the Upside down.
Which could mean the American
prisoner is in fact Hopper.
Side note, not everyone
thinks the American is Hopper.
Back to HouseHeisenb3rg,
who thinks the American
could be, this guy.
Ah yes, Dr. Brenner.
His fate has kinda been a
mystery since season two.
We thought he was dead
at the end of season one.
But then Eleven found out
he was actually alive.
According to this theory,
Brenner is the reason
the Russians knew about the Upside Down,
and the gate in Hawkins.
You might think, hey,
this is all well and good.
But surely, in the three
months since Hopper died
in potentially mysterious circumstances,
Eleven would've used her
powers to look for him.
Except, as some of you have pointed out,
her powers have gone, remember?
So how would she know?
Whatever happened to
Hopper, it can't be good.
If he's dead, well he's dead.
If not, he's potentially
either with the Russians,
who have a hungry Demogorgon.
Or in the Upside Down, with a Mind Flayer
who is super pissed.
He lost his weird bush monster body thing.
(screeching)
Now it's over to you, what do you think?
Do any of these theories hold weight?
Do you have any theories of your own.
Let us know in the comments below.
You know, so we can obsess about them too.